so earlier we told you about instagrams
possible plan to hide the number of
likes that users get on posed this is
just one of several steps that Instagram
is considering to fight bullying Pew
Research says about 72 percent of
teenagers use Instagram although a lot
of people think it's much higher than
that
we spoke to five kids from 12 to 18
years old Chantel Jackson Gaby a son
although he says call him son because
he's sexy and allison is words they are
all daily instagram users when we told
them that Instagram may hide likes to
take the pressure off users this group
had a whole lot to say about that we
will impose as much because it's like
what are you posting for they're never
going to an interaction with your phone
I guess that's the main thing you're
going for right yeah although the amount
of likes has like a really big negative
effect on people it also brings up some
kids self-esteem like if I have a post
and it gets under 200 likes I just
delete it likes are very important to
this group and getting those likes
requires work tell me this what's your
process in deciding what pictures you're
going to post so there's a lot of
thought going to one good one you take
50 pictures to get one picture to post
on Instagram what about you Gaby I've
taken 200 just stick that's the one good
picture to get one good picture show me
your good angle show me your bad angle
so like stick out my neck a little more
like tilt my head down I think my good
angle is anything above like the chin
anything below the chin you get like
that double chin when I'm taking a
picture with my friends standing up need
the left side what kind of pictures do
you notice it get the most likes the
ones you put the most effort in portrait
mode the enhancement white balance flash
law HDR what's the difference between
guys and girls me and my other leg
girlfriends we go outside like a whole
photo shoot we look at for the time of
day we try to get the right lighting and
guys will just post like a really bad
selfie again
a thousand likes I think girls have
higher standards though than guys
overall that's pretty much the same in
life yeah higher standard okay we asked
the head of Instagram Adam maseri about
the kids reaction the teenagers we
talked to were adamantly opposed to this
because they said the number matters to
them this could cost you business do you
think about that worried about that we
think about that we think about it but
we're gonna make decisions that mean
people use Instagram less if we think
it's better for our people's well-being
and if it resonates with enough you're
getting a true representation of what
people are really living and doing on
Instagram now because there's a lot of
people have their Instagram account and
they have their fake Instagram account
they're fin stuff mm-hmm
ever since that that's become a trend
people are more gravitated towards
Finster to put things on there that they
don't want everyone to see my mom always
told me that how I act is like a
representation of how like she acts or
how she raised me so I kind of like
based on that mmm you don't want to
disappoint her yes yeah I don't
disappoint my mom mm-hmm I like your mom
yeah how many of you have been cyber
bullied okay everyone has been cyber
bullied cyber bullying has so many
different meanings when I think of cyber
bullying I think of like pictures being
posted comments like me and comments
threats being thrown around it was just
like all called for and just mean and
heinous I tried to ignore it but the
problem with cyber bullying is that you
can't really escape it because you can't
escape your phone people have the most
conference online you have someone
saying you're so ugly you look like this
but at school they won't see anything to
you it's like confront them at school
you do and I'm like why'd you say that
but at school they're just like oh no
like I didn't mean that you said it
though
he may have been online but those were
still your words I instead you blocked
them because I'm wasting my time
confronting them and they're wasting
their time just focusing on me so have
you ever blocked someone and they know
that you blocked them and then you run
into them and what is that like that
that's was awkward it's awkward yeah
yeah very
it's even more awkward when you have
class with them you have to be with them
every day for the rest of the school
year why would people be upset if
they're blocked it could be such a
powerful thing where it's like okay we
hate each other now Instagram is testing
a comment warning feature using
technology that can flag unkind comments
and send a message to the user we say
you sure you want to say that do you
want to undo that we don't block you we
just say hey this looks like I might be
unkind do you want to undo it before I
send it or after I've said we're looking
at both right now do you think that's a
good thing it's not going to stop
cyberbullying altogether but I do think
that there are definitely people out
there who would take that into
consideration for sure I think kids are
just mean err today people have more
access to be mean to you so you can go
to school people are mean you can be
online people are mean and you don't
know what that person is going to at
home or anywhere else so people should
really like really think about what
they're saying there Chantel she has
last word that so those are five kids
who didn't know each other Bravo to the
CBS team the producers who found them
and put them together because you can
see they really have a lot to say and
they take this very very it's amazing
how much thought they put into every
post so to you know obviously a very
critical part of their lives and their
whole social network yes and it matters
to them they talked about the problems
with it I'm curious why do they do it in
the first place what do they like about
it because as one of them says you know
she said but it also builds your
self-esteem because you can see that
people like you and I said why do you
care that people you don't even know
like you - she said because it makes me
Gabby says it just makes me feel good
you know this makes me feel good
I felt like Nana in the room a couple
times you take 200 pictures you take 50
pictures so I'll take them and just put
it up there well it's simply because the
Instagram was created as this instant
thing yes you know very you know but
it's become this real focus of people's
lives the way they think about it's a
real thing